I tried recording this possible solution
to the bailout video just now but
apparently the the sound went bad so I
just restarted my computer so hopefully
I won't turn into slow-motion man again
well anyway the whole discussion so far
has been focused on how did the credit
crisis get started and why the current
bailout proposal 1 is wrong from just
from a moral hazard and fairness point
of view and why it probably won't work
even even to begin with so so you know
why even go into it and and some of you
said well you know what could be a
solution and I've argued a little bit in
the wealth destruction video that you
really can't legislate against reality
that you kind of have to let things
correct you cannot create wealth to just
by passing bills all you can kind of do
is shuffle around who takes the losses
but in one of the videos I I argued and
that you know if the government was
serious about helping Main Street about
loans to Main Street why don't they lend
directly to Main Street and I kind of
said it a little bit flippantly that if
that was their intention that's what
they should do with the 700 billion
dollars and I got a letter from an email
from a friend from business school very
intelligent fellow who I respect very
much and he essentially is wrecked he
has a solution that I think is
essentially that loan directly to Main
Street don't bail out these people who
have already acted extremely responsibly
irresponsibly and essentially write them
checks from American taxpayers and his
his discussion his his suggestion is
instead of buying worthless assets why
not create new banks fully capitalized
by the government but you might not even
have to capitalize them and let those
banks lend directly to Main Street and
he makes some very interesting points he
says let me let me make sure I can fit
all of this I don't know if you can read
it what this tall fit but he makes the
interesting point seven hundred billion
dollars of capital this is exact this is
his email that he sent to me with seven
hundred billion dollars of equity this
is more book equity and therefore more
lending power than Bank of America JP
Morgan Citigroup Washington Mutual
Wachovia Goldman Sachs and Morgan
Stanley combined so combined these
institutions which are really the
pillars of our financial
they represent 619 billion dollars of
book equity and remember this is what
this is their book equity this is what
they say is the book value of their
assets but we've already learned that
they're probably being being overstated
and that's why we have to go and buy
them at prices more than what they're
worth
but this 700 just to get an idea of how
large of a dollar amount this is this
700 billion is more than what these
banks say they're worth it's probably
several multiples of what they really
are worth some of these banks probably
aren't worth anything and as it points
out the new bank would have no prior
committed loans so the incremental
amount of lending available would be
much larger which means you are not
lending into a black hole when you when
you lend money or you essentially give
money to one of these banks that have
all of these other bad liabilities your
money is essentially just being poured
into a bat black hole and there's no
assurance that that bank is going to go
and then lend that money to other people
and go to Main Street but if you inject
it into a bank with a completely
pristine balance sheet a new Bank you
could call it you know the bank of
Washington the bank of Jefferson and I
would actually recommend having multiple
banks just so you have competition and
you don't have that too-big-to-fail
problem but these banks they would have
a pristine balance sheets and they would
go out and make loans and they would go
out and make loans wherever it is most
prudent and he says you know this
accomplishes the goal of injecting
lending capital into the system without
creating the moral hazard problem and at
the end of a few years the government
will probably be able to IPO sell the
bank for more than 1 Times Book value
which will include the original 700
billion generating a substantial profit
to taxpayer exactly in fact they could
either do that the bet the government
could own it and then try to IPO it in
five years or so like like Todd suggests
or another option is maybe each of these
banks maybe the bank takes 700 billion
and creates 10 banks that each have 70
billion in initial equity capital and
maybe the government issues 300 million
shares of each of those banks and every
American man woman and child gets one
share of each of those banks I think
they would have a very powerful
political statement it actually would
make economic sense all of a sudden you
would have the American people are now
the owners of the banking system instead
of this concentrated wealth that's
really for
over the past 150 years in the old
banking system and then you know he goes
on to point out some other things sure
the more current banks would fail
probably quicker and and we all know
that's a good thing what happened in
Japan what happened in Japan is we kept
infusing capital into what we didn't the
Japanese government kept infusing or
either did it themselves or coaxed other
people to infuse capital into banks that
were essentially zombie banks that were
insolvent and just slowed down it had
the slowdown the downfall and
essentially led to their lost decades so
he says you know more banks would fail
but many of them probably deserved to
fail in the financial system would be
preserved I agree with them completely
if the new bank wants to lend new money
to new borrowers it can or if it thinks
it will make more money buying up old
loans like the CDOs or the residential
mortgage-backed securities at a deep
discount it can do this too but it will
be making a clear economic profit
decision and I'd add just so that we
make sure that the management of these
of these new entities so that they are
aligned with profit-making as opposed to
bailing out their own previous past bad
decisions or bailing out the people who
they used to work with I would try to
not put these banks in New York maybe
you put them in Detroit and New Orleans
and Stockton California which is a
foreclosure capital of the world of the
country put them in places that are
separate from Wall Street hire very
intelligent people who are have some
distance from what has happened the last
five six years in Michigan I'll tell you
there are tons and tons of very
competent very intelligent managers who
understand these issues deeply in this
country unfortunately a lot of them
haven't been heads of banks lately and
they would be happy to work for
something less than twenty million
dollars a year in fact I think many of
them would do it out of patriotic duty
but you could pay them a hundred
thousand dollars a year and then you
could say you know what you as the the
new employees of these new American
banks that are owned by the American
people and they can be traded on an
exchange let's essentially immediately
privatize it's never owned by the
government it's immediately owned by the
private sector by the American people
not by the government when I say
American people it's literally owned by
private individuals not by the
government but you can actually create
an incentive structure that whatever
the equity value of your company is in
five years out you all as the employees
share 1% of the of the of the benefit
and access actually a huge number that
actually might be too much but you will
be able to hire excellent managers
especially considering how many people
are getting laid off right now very
intelligent people because of bad risky
decisions made by others but then he
finishes up I recognized this will be
less politically popular among banking
lobbyists but see it as a much better
way to one protect the financial system
I agree with him completely
to minimize the risk maximize the reward
to the US government and he welcomes any
comments criticisms and I think it's
interesting he started off the the the
idea he says the problem is this sort of
plan would be political suicide with key
financial donors to political campaigns
and that's true unfortunately this this
I think this is a good idea but I think
the current old banking system has a
much more receptive ear of our of our
government unfortunately than I or Todd
or frankly the American people seem to
have right now but anyway let's just you
know I was kind of parsing Todd's email
let's at me let me actually draw out a
plan of what this would be so you take
700 billion dollars and let me write
that out 700 a thousand that's million
that's a billion you take that 700
billion and you I don't know you put it
I think the more banks the better you
want competition you don't want to have
this too big to fail problem so you take
that 700 billion and the first time I
record this video I said you put it in
10 banks but I don't know let's put it
in if you put it let's see if you 700
divided by 10 banks would be seventy
billion each if you do seven if you do
what if you do 70 banks you would have
10 billion each so let's do that put it
in 70 different banks 70 different banks
or maybe do it in 50 different banks in
one bank for each state of the country
70 different banks I mean that sounds
crazy but when you think about what the
government was originally go I should
let's do 50 banks I like the sound of
that
one bank in in every state right I think
and and it they're not all concentrated
in in New York and they're not you know
so you have you you get fresh thought
fresh blood in them and they actually
might that they might actually hire
people that that are getting laid off in
the manufacturing sector or the or the
real estate sector or whatever you take
50 different banks you capitalize them
each with what 50 goes into 700 billion
one point what 14 times right 14 let's
see 15 right goes 14 times so you
capitalized them each with 14 billion
dollars so their balance sheets are
going to look like this equity this is
each Bank 14 billion of original of
initial equity and this is going they're
going to have 300 million shares million
shares one for every American and if
they don't like the holding shares the
bank they can sell them all all IPO in
the exchanges and then these will be
member banks of the Fed and so they can
they can they'll be regulated but they
can lever up ten to one so they can
let's say with 14 billion dollars of
assets each of these banks can control
one hundred with fourteen billion of
equity each of these banks can control
one hundred forty billion of assets
which essentially that's 140 billion
that they can lend out to the world if
they see good returns good economic
investment in Main Street they'll do it
there if they think that some of the
existing banks are actually good credit
risks that they could lend maybe to JP
Morgan or Bank of America they'll do it
maybe they won't do it at six percent
like the Fed wants them to or at two
percent or whatever they'll say it's a
little risky or maybe I'll do it at ten
or twelve percent and this is another
side note I'd like to say who it seems
like the Fed is getting frustrated that
it wants to dictate that banks have to
lend to each other two percent but
they're willing to only lend to each
other at six percent and so it's losing
control over that that notion of what
banks lend to each other at six percent
is still low if I had to lend money to
someone who could go under next week I
want at least twelve or fifteen percent
and I don't think that's a crazy
interest rate that's what people were
paying in the early 80s and they weren't
talking about financial Armageddon back
then but anyway each of these banks
would have 140 billion in assets and
then I don't know how much in liability
one forty minus 14 is 124 billion in
liabilities and they would be very easy
to raise to borrow money these banks
would have an easy time borrowing money
from a bunch of different people and why
is that well one they have completely
pristine balance sheets no one worries
about what kind of stinky things they
have on there on this side because it's
all new investments and then if the if
the government really wants to make sure
that these banks get off the ground
running they can put a they can put make
them a temporary government a backstop
on it so essentially they could be
government-sponsored enterprises but not
indefinitely we don't want a Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac again you could say
five-year government backstop five-year
government backstop which essentially
says if you lend to these banks over the
next five years
anyone lending to these banks over the
next five years if for whatever reason
these banks were to go under you will be
made whole so there's literally no risk
to investing in these banks and frankly
frankly if just this five year
government banks top government backstop
on these banks I think will encourage
people to invest equity in these banks
and the government might not even have
to put these 14 billion in each bank but
anyway I've run out of time I'll
continue this in the next video